hi this is Kim from Khan Academy and
today we're learning more about Brown
versus Board of Education of Topeka
decided in 1954 Brown versus Board was a
landmark case that opened the door for
desegregation and the modern civil
rights movement in Brown the Supreme
Court ruled that segregated schools for
white and black children which had been
prevalent throughout the American South
since the 1896 decision in Plessy versus
Ferguson legalized segregation were in
fact inherently unequal the named
plaintiff in this case Oliver Brown was
the father of Linda a third grader who
had to take a bus to a segregated
elementary school that was much farther
from her home than the nearby school for
white children to learn more about the
brown case I sought out the help of two
experts Theodore Shaw is the Julius L
chambers distinguished professor of law
and director of the center for civil
rights at the University of North
Carolina School of Law Michael McConnell
is the Richard and Francis Malory
professor and director of the
constitutional law Center at Stanford
Law School and a senior fellow at the
Hoover Institution so professor Shaw
could you just kind of set the stage for
us what was the overall social and
political context behind this case well
Brown was decided in the Cold War era I
think that's important for reasons that
I'll come back to but it also was
decided I guess it was fifty eight years
after the Supreme Court ruled and Plessy
versus Ferguson that separate but equal
Railway cars were constitutional of
course that extended to all walks of
life in the south and so what you had
was Jim Crow segregation sustained and
set in place by law and Brown was the
case that cracked the edifice of Jim
Crow segregation so it was an enormous
ly important case it came after a long
campaign by the n-double-a-cp Legal
Defense Fund to overturn Plessy one
thing that I think is really confusing
about Plessy versus Ferguson
is how it interacts with the 14th
amendment so immediately after the Civil
War Congress passed and the states
ratified the 14th amendment which gives
equal protection under the law to all
citizens
but then Plessy vs. Ferguson just a
couple decades later legalizes
segregation can you talk a little bit
more about how the Equal Protection
Clause of the 14th amendment has been
interpreted in Plessy and then later in
Brown versus Board the doctrine of
separate but equal was itself a
departure from from the prior
understanding of what the 14th amendment
meant in the immediate wake of the 14th
amendment segregation was understood to
be a violation of equal rights thus the
Congress of the United States passed the
Civil Rights Act of 1875 which
prohibited mandatory segregation of of
among other things railroads now that
was struck down and 1883 I believe it
was 1886 but for reasons not related to
separate but equal or segregation but
it's only in the late 1880s and 1890s
the states began passing Jim Crow
legislation like the law and Plessy
versus Ferguson
I mean Plessy very likely would have
been would have come out a different way
had it come up 25 years earlier it's
really very difficult to understand the
logic of Plassey because Plessy takes
the point of view that segregation is
okay because it treats everyone the same
way and the sense of inferiority or
insult that comes from a segregation the
court just just ignored you can read the
opinion different ways and people do and
have read the EM in different ways a
portion of the opinion makes
sound as though this is a kind of social
science conclusion that that segregation
breeds a feeling of inferiority that has
a deleterious effect on the black
students performance in school
there's a famous footnote in Brown
versus Board of Education footnote 11 in
which some social sciences scientists
and particularly a dr. Kenneth Clark did
a series of tests the dahle tests in
which they showed black and white dolls
who are otherwise identical to little
children little black children and they
asked who was a good doll who was the
bad dog who was too pretty doll who was
the ugly doll and the black children
would invariably choose the white dolls
as the better dolls and the black dolls
as the inferior dolls and then finally
the bombshell question which one looks
like you and they would stop and choose
the the black doll and many times
cheetahs will come to their eyes and so
this old notion of the inferiority that
segregation imbued in black
schoolchildren was important and the
Supreme Court had some very eloquent
language about that everyone knew that
the only reason to have laws requiring
black and white to be separate was
because of the feeling on the part of
the dominant white group that that the
African race was inferior I think it was
a it was a failure of political will
really rather than a matter of of
constitution or a legal logic that led
to that and then it took what almost 60
years before the Supreme Court would
turn itself around the late of a Leon
Higginbotham who sat on the Court of
Appeals for the Third Circuit and
Philadelphia he used to say that Plessy
was wrong the day was decided and I
believe he was right about that
if you go back and look at the rationale
stated and Plessy it's it's not didn't
hold up it's not an intellectually
honest decision and having said that if
you look at Brown it really did not
overrule Plessy on its face with respect
to segregation and Jim Crow across the
board what it did was say that in the
field of public education separate but
equal is unconstitutional separate
schools cannot be equal and what
followed Brown was a series of cases in
all kinds of areas in which the court
sometimes without much of an opinion
cited Brown but struck down segregation
and public libraries and public
accommodations and transportation etc
the case that settled the long-running
boycott in Montgomery Alabama that
catapulted Martin Luther King into the
national and world stage you know it was
decided it was his all finally the
boycott was important but it was
resolved by this case that the Supreme
Court decided and it cited Brown so
Thurgood Marshall and the Legal Defense
Fund had kind of been chipping away at
the edges of segregation and then they
turned directly to school segregation in
the brown cases so what kind of
arguments did they use to challenge the
system of school segregation Thurgood
Marshall and his co-counsel and then
double ACP established a very careful
strategy of one case at a time sort of
pushing the envelope of this idea that
segregation is inconsistent with the
demands of equal protection and the
interesting thing about Brown itself the
brown the case challenging segregation
and Topeka Kansas you know why Topeka
Kansas
why is this why was this such an
excellent
a place to raise the challenge and the
reason is that the schools and Topeka
were very substantially equal in quality
in Topeka they actually had integrated
high schools and middle schools it was
only the elementary schools that were
segregated and the district court found
and the Supreme Court did not disagree
that in terms of their material
advantages that the black school is
essentially just as good as the light
school and that's why the n-double-a-cp
wanted to go after Topeka because then
it went to the principle of the thing
you know it's one thing to attack a
segregation when separate but equal is
really just a fiction but when separate
but equal is a reality at least pretty
close to it as in Topeka you have to go
after the actual principle that
segregation is wrong in principle and
not just wrong because it tends most of
the time to lead to material
disadvantage Brown was actually five
cases the brown case itself came from
Topeka Kansas in many ways the Supreme
Court might have chosen to Lee with the
brown case because it wasn't part of the
south and so in some ways it might have
been viewed as taking pressure off of
the south but there were five cases
altogether there was a case out of South
Carolina a case out of Virginia case out
of Delaware case out of Washington DC
and then the Topeka case and the brown
family was actually not even the only
family named brown and Topeka case and
the other brown case did not have their
father available as the lead voice and
they wanted a man and so Oliver Brown
was the one they chose they stipulated
that the schools were in fact equal in
all respects and of course they weren't
it was never possible to make separate
but equal equal but they stipulated that
these hooves were equal the black and
white schools because they wanted the
court to be able to or to have to
confront the issue of whether separate
but equal per se was unconstitutional
interesting so it's this this place
where they're hoping not to have a
ruling that for example oh the the
schools for black children need to be
brought up to code to be the same as
white children but they're trying to
strike down the idea of segregation
altogether and indeed they rule
unanimously that separate but equal
facilities are inherently unequal the
Supreme Court in Brown says well
whatever may have been the status of
education as a civil right back then
back in the 19th century by now it
surely is a civil right and therefore
cannot there can be no discrimination
with regard to it then one other thing
that changed that I think the Supreme
Court doesn't refer to but many
historians think was surely in the back
of their minds has to do with foreign
policy of all things that during this
time the United States and the wake of
World War two was playing a very major
role in opposing colonialism opposing
communism and trying to spread the
gospel of Liberty around the world and
when we had segregation at home this
looked like rank hypocrisy this was the
Cold War period
these soldiers came home from fighting a
form of racism in Europe Nazi Germany
you know the Holocaust and when they
came back they came back to segregated
America and there are many stories that
are painful about what their experiences
were but meanwhile the United States is
having his cold war with the Soviet
Union and the Soviet Union was
exploiting this inconsistency and what
America
said it was and what it was and though
the Supreme Court never said a word
about that in the brown cases that was
very much context for that decision so
what did it take first desegregation to
really come about do you think we've
we've achieved desegregation yes and no
there was a long battle to implement
Brown and in fact for the most part
Brown was not implemented fully to the
extent it ever was until the early 1970s
when the Supreme Court decided a case
called Swann Bruce's
charlotte-mecklenburg Board of Education
in North Carolina and sanctioned the use
of busing this does not depend upon what
social scientists might think about how
people do in school this is a much more
fundamental principle of equality under
the law that our law must treat black
and white the same that for the
government to draw racial distinctions
as fundamentally unequal and
unconstitutional and wrong and unjust
fundamentally so and not just as a
matter of social science evidence I
don't want to sound despairing you know
it but I think if anybody looks at our
public schools today in many of our
communities and our towns and cities and
our counties we have to acknowledge
honestly that there's still a great deal
of segregation and there are many
schools that are identifiably why do
identifiably black and now you know
Latinos Hispanics large degree of
segregation they're also and even
voluntary desegregation efforts have
been found by the Supreme Court a few
years ago to be largely unconstitutional
and illegal and that's tragic but that
doesn't mean that Brown
wasn't significant I was born in the
year Brown versus Board of Education the
America that I grew up in is a very
different country than the one that
preceded it in spite of our flaws and
our warts
no Brown versus Board of Education no
civil rights movement I would say and
ultimately no desegregation of our
society to the extent that we've
accomplished it and we have to a great
degree know Barack Obama so I I think
Brown stands as I said as a dividing
point in America but we we can do better
so we've learned that under the
leadership of Thurgood Marshall and the
n-double-a-cp Legal Defense Fund the
decision in Brown versus Board of
Education struck a major blow to the
system of segregation after World War
Two amidst the ideological struggle of
the Cold War the Supreme Court
overturned the precedent set in Plessy
versus Ferguson and ruled that
segregated education constituted a
violation of the Equal Protection Clause
of the Fourteenth Amendment to learn
more about Brown versus Board visit the
National Constitution Center's
interactive Constitution and Khan
Academy's resources on US government and
politics